Okay, so welcome back to the screen. We're
going to get stuck in now to video number
12, our next leading indicator. Leading
indicator number eight, cyclical commodity
prices. And let's have a look at what
we've covered so far. We've covered a lot
of leading indicators now. You can see
we're accumulating throughout the video
series.
The first part of the PTM accumulating
multiple leading indicators. We've covered
the money markets, and we've covered
surveys. And now we're going to be adding
in cyclical commodity prices. And we're
going to be covering oil, copper, lumber,
and iron ore. And we're also going to be
covering currencies. So we're going to be
looking specifically at the
The US dollar trade weighted indices. But
before we get into that, we need to do a
bit of background work and a bit of
information on inflation. Why? Because if
we're going to understand cyclical
commodity prices, and US dollar trade
weighted indices, it's important to
understand what inflation is, how
inflation works.
How it fits into our overall framework.
Now, having a low and stable rate of
inflation in an economy is an essential
part of a healthy capitalist system. What
we need is a stable and predictable rate
of price inflation of goods and services.
And what this does is it provides a
foundation that enables a stable rate of
goods and services.
of real GDP growth of real GDP growth and
employment. So the ideal situation, let's
cover that first. What we want in a
healthy economy is a good level of nominal
GDP growth and a stable, positive rate of
inflation that's lower than the rate of
nominal GDP growth. And that gives us
positive real GDP and a predictable rate
of GDP.
of GDP. So this is considered to be an
ideal situation in the economy. Really,
it's what the Fed is looking for with,
obviously, with their dual mandate, strong
levels of employment. But, you know, we
can also have other situations occurring
at any one moment in time. We can have the
non-ideal situation, which is bad. Okay.
We can also have high levels of positive
price changes. So we're getting inflation
or negative price changes where we're
getting price deflation. And we can have
inflation volatility. Conditions like this
are considered to be not ideal or even
bad. And what we can do is we can analyze
historical inflation data.
So we can observe what are considered to
be normal. So ideal inflationary
conditions. And abnormal. So non-ideal
inflationary or even deflationary
conditions. And we can look at the data
set. And we can see big positive and
negative changes in price inflation.
So moves away from normal conditions. And
what we find is, is that these abnormal
conditions are in the significant
minority.
Now, how is inflation measured and
presented? Well, we're going to be looking
at a few measures here just for some
background information so you understand
this better.
We're going to be looking at CPI, the
Consumer Price Index, and the PPI, which
is the Producer Price Index.
So let's start with CPI. The CPI stats are
split into two different measures.
One is including food and energy, and one
is excluding food and energy.
And the data is released monthly from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics.
And the link is on the screen there where
you can get the monthly news release.
Now, the data for CPI can be downloaded at
the second link on the screen, and it goes
back as far as 1947.
And it's constructed by taking the
weighted averages of prices on a wide
variety of items, which are basically
assigned weights, representing their
importance within certain groups.
And the prices are collected on a monthly
basis from 4,000 housing units and around
26,000 retail establishments across
cities, across 87 urban areas of the
United States.
Now, this is obviously a large data set,
so it's a significant number.
And of course, there's a lot of importance
placed on inflation by the Federal Reserve
in its dual mandate to maintain a certain
level of inflation and a target
employment.
Now, this data set, obviously, it's a big
one, and this is because this is for the
CPI all items measure, okay?
So, 4,000 housing units and 26,000 retail
establishments across the 87 urban areas
of the U.S.
But it's very important to remember, guys,
that CPI and inflation data in the U.S. is
a coincident indicator.
It's telling us what is happening in the
economy now rather than in the future.
So, it's not as useful as leading
indicators because the CPI follows our
leading indicators.
By definition, inflation data is telling
us what happened to prices in the previous
month.
However, it is useful to us.
We do need to know, obviously, the level
of inflation in the economy.
It's still useful as a confirmation
indicator because the Fed can be,
obviously, reactionary.
And therefore, interest rate policy based
on inflation expectations can, obviously,
be affected.
But always remember that it's a coincident
indicator.
So, we use it as traders and portfolio
managers as a confirmation indicator to
essentially confirm what we were seeing in
the leading indicators in previous months.
So, this is the all items number.
So, this is including food and energy.
So, links on the screen there.
Data is very easy to get.
You just hit the download button at the
St. Louis Fed link and the data drops into
a spreadsheet.
Next up, the CPI-X food and energy.
There's another link there for St. Louis
Fed.
You can download the data there.
And the data goes back as far as 1957.
It's calculated in the same way as the all
items number.
However, the goods included do not include
any food items and items that are linked
to the price of energy, including oil.
Now, the CPI-X food and energy number is
sometimes referred to in the market as the
core CPI number.
Because it measures core inflation in the
U.S. without having the exposure to
international food and energy prices that
can essentially be volatile
and subject to exogenous influences in the
global marketplace that are outside of the
control of the central authorities in the
U.S.
Now, again, CPI-X food and energy.
It's taken from the same data set,
reported monthly, and backwards looking.
So, it's again a coincident indicator.
So, we can use it, again, as a
confirmation indicator.
Because the Fed, of course, is not always
predicting what's going to happen and
trying to prevent what's going to happen.
The Fed can also be reactionary.
And it's just knowledge that we must have.
We need to know at any one moment in time,
as traders and PMs, what is actually
happening with inflation in the economy.
So, that's how inflation is measured in
the U.S. for consumers.
All items, including food and energy, and
ex-food and energy.
So, the CPI, all items, and the CPI,
What about businesses?
Well, we have a measure for inflation for
businesses as well.
So, this is called the producer price
index.
So, the PPI.
And the data for PPI, all commodities, can
be downloaded, again, following that link
at the St. Louis Fed.
The data goes back as far as 1913, and
it's indexed to 100 in 1982.
And the data is different from the
consumer data, the CPI, because it
measures input costs or prices for
businesses that make products and provide
services, whereas the CPI only measures
prices that are facing consumers.
Now, the way the BLS puts the all
commodities index together, basically,
price change data is indexed for the
commodities, indexed and analyzed for a
whole bunch of commodities and input
prices across a whole bunch of industries.
And this makes up the overall all
commodities index, and the list of those
industries, and there's an index for each
one.
So, the list of the industries and those
indices can be found at the St. Louis Fed
link on the screen.
And all of these commodities that are
indexed basically make up the all
commodities index.
Now, the PPI, all commodities index, is,
again, a coincidence indicator, but it is,
of course, useful to us still, as traders
and PMs, as a confirmation indicator,
because, again, the Fed can be reactionary
instead of possibly being preventative.
Now, our three inflation measures, so our
monthly CPI, all items, our monthly CPI,
X, food and energy, and our PPI, all
commodities index, so released on a
monthly basis as well.
So, these are our three inflation
measures.
We can obviously get the data from the St.
Louis Fed website, and we can do a
statistical analysis of it.
And what we do is we do a distribution of
returns analysis on the inflation data
itself.
And the reason we do this is because what
we want to understand is what is happening
with inflation at any one moment in time
in the economy.
So, what we have to do is look to the
historical data and understand inflation
and what it actually means when it moves.
So, as a student of the financial markets,
as a student of macroeconomics, what you
need to do is have a look at the data sets
and understand the moves in inflation and
what it actually means.
So, basically, in the future, you'll
understand the context of any inflation
data when it comes out and be able to
understand it better because you'll have
it in a historical context.
Now, the way in which we analyze the
inflation stats is very similar to the way
in which we analyzed the N2 money supply
data earlier in the PTM video series and
the various tradable instruments in the
IPLT video series.
So, we calculate a distribution of returns
to discover what is a normal level of
inflation and what is an abnormal level of
inflation in order to assess future
monthly moves.
So, we take the monthly index levels that
are reported by the BLS throughout history
and we work out percentage changes on a
month-by-month basis and then we run a
statistical distribution analysis.
So, in the future, when we analyze any
inflation data releases, we can
distinguish between what is considered to
be a normal move and what is considered to
be an abnormal move for inflation.
Now, you know how to use the method to
analyze data.
So, if you have a self-starter mentality,
which I hope you do, in your own time, you
can use the same approach that we utilized
with the N2 money supply in the PTM video
series and those tradable instruments in
the IPLT video series
And determine both normal, so within one
standard deviation, and abnormal, so
outside one standard deviation or even two
and three standard deviation moves in
consumer and producer prices.
Now, it's always obviously good to know
the level of inflation in the economy, but
as traders and PMs, we of course, we'd
rather want to predict inflation rather
than react to it.
So, we must remember, we've got to
remember that the CPI and the PPI are
coincident indicators and not leading
indicators.
Commodities prices themselves lead the
commodities price indices.
So, each month, by the time you analyze
the monthly indices for our three
inflation numbers, the CPI, all items, the
CPI, x food and energy, and the PPI, all
commodities, really, there should be no
surprises, because for the previous month,
you will have been on top of all the major
commodity price moves.
Now, if you're sitting there thinking to
yourself, Anton, this is all great, you
know, about inflation, et cetera, but I
really can't be bothered downloading all
the data and doing all of the work to
figure out what is a normal and abnormal
move for all three of these inflation
indices.
Well, if you're thinking that,
unfortunately, you're defaulting to a
position of not being a self-starter, but
seeing as though it's early days in the
educational process, we do have a
downloads area, and we've done the work
for you.
But I would encourage you to go into the
inflation, CPI, and PPI file, and go
through the formulas, and work out how the
data is all set out, and work out from the
formulas how the sheet actually works.
And you'll see the method is exactly the
same as when we looked at M2 money supply,
and when we looked at, in the IPLT video
series, the various tradable instruments
across asset classes.
So, what you should be doing first is
obviously downloading the inflation, CPI,
and PPI file, looking at how it's all
worked out, and then actually running
through the process yourself, and just
practicing.
So, in the same way that you practice the
method with the M2 money supply data and
tradeable asset data, you need to do this
with inflation data as well.
Now, we also have some other downloads, so
there's multiple downloads for this video.
We have our cyclical commodity prices, we
have our commitment of traders, reports
for metals and energy, we also have our US
dollar trade weighted index analysis, and
we also have a summary file.
And by the way, all the data sources are
included in the files.
So, for example, the links that were on
the screen earlier for inflation, they're
all included in the file, and you can just
easily click on them.
But let's start with cyclical commodity
prices.
In the downloads area, in the sheet for
cyclical commodity prices, you're going to
notice that we've covered a whole bunch of
them.
So, we've got oil, copper, lumber and iron
ore.
So, in oil, we're covering WTI and Brent
and the WTI Brent spread.
For copper, there's multiple contracts
that trade globally, and we've covered
them all in the downloads area.
So, there's copper that's traded on COMEX,
copper that's traded on the London Metal
Exchange, copper that's traded on the
Shanghai Futures Exchange.
And then we're looking at various spreads.
We're looking at the COMEX LME spread, and
the LME Shanghai spread.
For lumber, we're looking at the most
popular contract, the random length lumber
contract, which is on the CME.
And for iron ore, we're looking at two
contracts in the downloads.
We're looking at the iron ore contract on
CME, and the iron ore contract in China,
on the Dalian Commodities Exchange, the
DCE.
Now, what you will notice when you look at
each of these cyclical commodities, you'll
notice that we've downloaded all the price
data for each of those cyclical
commodities.
And in the same way, using the same method
that we use for the inflation data, and
the M2 money supply data, and all the
other tradable instruments that we looked
at in the IPLT video series,
we've conducted a distribution of returns,
statistical analysis on the cyclical
commodity prices.
And we've done that to ascertain what is a
normal, so within one standard deviation
move, and abnormal, so outside a one
standard deviation move.
And looking at also two standard deviation
and three standard deviation moves for
each of those cyclical commodities on both
a daily and weekly time horizon.
Now, additionally, in the downloads area,
you'll notice a file called the summary
file.
And this summary file puts all in one
sheet, the analysis of the standard
deviation moves in all of the instruments
that we're going to be looking at,
from minus three standard deviation move
to positive three standard deviation move,
for basically all the tradable instruments
in our cyclical commodity space.
Now, why do we do this? Why do we go
through this exercise?
Why is it actually important? Well,
cyclical commodities often move with the
business cycle, so with economic growth.
The clue is in the name, cyclicality. They
move with the business cycle.
So, if you think back to our other
business cycle indicators, so the ISM
manufacturing, ISM non-manufacturing, the
University of Michigan Consumer Sentiment
Index,
building permits, and the NFIB, and the
NFIB Small Business Optimism Index, if you
think of all of those business cycle
indicators that are leading indicators,
cyclical commodities essentially move with
them.
They move and tend to lead as a gauge to
the business cycle.
The cyclical commodity prices themselves
are indicative of future CPI and PPI
levels, which are reported monthly, and
future economic growth, so real GDP
reported quarterly.
So, expansion and contraction, so
expansion and contraction in the economy.
And of course, both real GDP and inflation
are reported after the fact.
Cyclical commodity prices are open quotes
leading close quotes because they are
trading and moving every day.
And then inflation is reported monthly,
and then economic growth, real GDP, is
reported quarterly, and they are both
reported after the fact.
So, let's think of an example here.
So, a leading indicator like the ISM
manufacturing number may tell us at one
point in time, as traders, that there is a
turning point occurring in purchasing
manager expectations for the future.
So, what would that look like?
Well, they may be reporting new orders
growth after a contraction or growth is
accelerating, so there could be a turning
point or a trend.
And this can be combined with, for
example, growth in inventory stocking and
increases, their reporting increases in
key input commodity prices to the
manufacturing process.
So, what does that mean?
Well, it means we're getting higher
commodity prices, and we have to assume
here, as in the example, that we have a
constant supply of the commodity.
So, supply is not moving.
So, we're concentrating on demand here.
So, it means that there's higher commodity
prices given a constant supply in real
time, because businesses are buying more
input commodities, and this feeds into the
inflation statistics later, when they're
reported on a monthly basis, and prices,
by the time inflation is reported, have
already moved.
So, what we need to understand with
cyclical commodities is what is a normal
and abnormal move, and use cyclical
commodity prices as a gauge to shifts in
inflation expectations.
Now, think in the bigger picture, what
we're trying to achieve here as traders
and PMs.
From a macro perspective, we are always
trying to gauge which way the wind is
blowing to enable a prediction of real GDP
growth and likely S&P 500 direction and
returns, and of course, potential Fed
policy.
Why do we do this?
Well, throughout the PTM video series,
it's been clear.
We do this so we can position ourselves
with the right directional bias.
So, a portfolio of net long, net short, or
neutral positioning, and of course, with
the right longs and shorts in the
portfolio.
So, this is how we use them as traders and
portfolio managers, how we use cyclical
commodities to make a more intelligent
decision around portfolio bias and
potentially what we want to be long and
short in a portfolio.
So, we have to keep an eye on commodity
prices and inflation expectations and
understand them and interpret them and
what it all means at any one moment in
time.
Now, we have to think about something else
as well.
So, for commodities themselves, there are
inventory dynamics, which has supply side
dynamics that we have to understand.
So, there is a supply side caveat here
with cyclical commodities.
So, for commodities themselves, as
inventories are rising, this indicates a
rise in demand.
So, business or purchasing managers are
increasing demand and increasing their own
inventories.
And we know that's a bullish indication.
On the flip side, if inventories are
falling, this indicates a falling demand.
So, business and purchasing managers are
reducing their demand and reducing their
own inventories.
And they're consciously doing this for
both cases.
So, rising inventories is indicating a
rise in demand from purchasing managers.
And that would be indicating bullish
conditions.
So, for these cyclical commodities in the
energy and industrial metals space, within
these companies, there are internally
traders of energy and industrial metals
commodities.
And they are increasing or decreasing
their stocking levels in accordance with
actual and expected demand.
So, given a constant supply, prices that
are increasing and decreasing are a gauge
on business or purchasing managers' actual
and expectation of demand.
But there is a caveat to all of this.
Prices are, of course, a function of both
demand and supply dynamics.
So, it's not an automatic function that
prices must follow expected demand.
And, of course, there can also be cost
push or supply factors that we have to
consider as to why prices are where they
are at any one time.
And we'll come to this in a moment.
We have a PDF download to help with this.
But, however, we must always be on top of
commodity prices and inflation
expectations and know why cyclical
commodities are where they are.
This is our interpretation at any one
moment in time.
Are demand factors outstripping supply
factors or vice versa?
And if we have a particular cyclical
commodity where demand factors are very
clearly outstripping supply factors, then,
of course, as traders and portfolio
managers, we're going to find that very
useful as a leading indicator.
And if supply factors are outstripping
demand factors at any one moment in time,
then it's going to be difficult for us to
use that commodity price as a leading
indicator to potential future economic
growth and stock market direction and
returns.
Now, we have, as I mentioned, a PDF in the
download area.
The name of that PDF is Cyclical
Commodities Demand and Supply Factors.
And in the download, what you'll notice is
there's a whole bunch of sources and
information relating to the oil, copper,
lumber and iron ore markets.
So you can essentially, at any one moment
in time, analyze those factors and gauge
whether demand factors are outstripping
supply factors for the commodity price
move.
So this is going to be a useful resource
for you going forward.
So when you see a cyclical commodity price
move, you can use the resource and
determine whether it's a demand-led move
or a supply-led move.
Now, obviously, earlier in this video, we
looked at the CPI and the PPI.
So the consumer price index and the
producer price index.
And we're looking here in a bit more
detail now at the PPI All Commodities
Index.
And we're going to look at the
contributory data behind this number.
If you look at the screen, you'll see at
the bottom of the page, you'll see a link
that takes you from the FRED chart and the
download data area on the FRED website for
the PPI All Commodities Index.
The link there takes you to the commodity
groupings that make up the headline index,
which is the index currently on the
screen.
And when you click on that link, you get
taken to another page, and the page shows
you all of the commodities contributory
indices that contribute to the All
Commodities Index.
So you can see on the screen, on the
left-hand side, you can see all
commodities under the heading goods.
So all commodities comes under this
heading.
And then underneath all commodities, you
can see all of the various commodities
that contribute under the heading of
goods.
So under the category of goods, and these
create the index for all commodities.
Now, there's other categories.
There's other commodity groupings.
So that's on the left-hand side, as you
can see on the screen.
But on the right-hand side, we also have
services and construction.
And other commodity groupings and services
and construction are not included in the
overall All Commodities number.
The All Commodities number comes under
goods.
But if you look at, for example, other
commodity groupings, you can see that a
lot of the commodities that are listed
there, there's a big overlap with the
contributory indices that contribute to
the All Commodities number.
So because there's a big overlap, the All
Commodities number, and the contributory
data, because there's a big overlap,
there's a very good representation of the
other commodity groupings inside the
index.
What isn't represented is obviously
services and construction, although many
of the commodities that we see on the
left-hand side will be input prices to the
construction industry.
But let's recall from our previous
analysis of the manufacturing and
non-manufacturing sectors of the economy
when we were analyzing ISM data.
So if you recall, manufacturing makes up
20% of the US economy and
non-manufacturing, so services, makes up
80% of the economy.
As traders and PMs, we don't have access
to tradable commodities that we can
sensibly use as leading indicators to all
industries within the service sector and
therefore the overall service sector.
However, we do have access to cyclical
commodities like oil, copper, lumber and
iron ore on a daily basis.
So although we don't get a perfect
representation of services, the services
side of the economy, there's undeniably an
overlap in certain areas.
So services within certain service sector
industries are linked very clearly to
final demand like cyclical commodities.
There's an overlap in many areas.
So for example, in real estate services,
if there's, for example, a housing
slowdown where we have lower building
permits that are leading to fewer housing
starts and housing completions, then
naturally the demand for lumber will go
down.
If we're assuming a constant supply, so
there's no supply issues in the lumber
market, then the lumber price will fall
and real estate services, which are part
of the service side of the economy, should
slow down or contract.
So if we see, for example, deflation or
inflation in a certain commodity price and
it's demand-led, if there's an overlap
into the service sector, then of course,
this cyclical commodity price is
potentially leading and overlapping many
areas of the service sector.
So it becomes obviously useful to us as
traders and PMs.
Additionally, we can always, of course,
look at a particular service sector area
and look at the industry index itself to
gauge inflation and growth.
So, for example, when you're looking at
data sets and hunting around for data sets
and index levels on the FRED website, you
can look, for example, at a particular
index and here we've drilled down to the
real estate services sector.
And if you look on the left-hand side, at
the bottom of the screenshot, you can see
a link called services, real estate
services partial.
And when you click on that, so when you're
on the index page and looking at the
chart, if you click on that link on the
bottom, you'll be taken to a page that
shows you all of the sub-indexes that make
up the real estate services index.
And you can see, for example, gross rents
across the property sector.
You can see non-residential property sales
and leasing with land brokerage fees and
commissions.
You can also see management fees and you
can see residential property sales and
rentals, brokerage fees and commissions
and also appraisal fees.
So, very obviously, if we're using lumber
as one of our cyclical commodity prices
that we're analyzing, if we get demand-led
inflation or deflation, this can be a good
leading indicator to a particular sector
like real estate services.
So, services we do not necessarily have or
need the ability to be able to look at
leading indicators that are directly
leading into, for example, real estate
commissions and brokerage fees.
We know if there's a slowdown in the
housing sector, in the construction
sector, if lumber is falling, for example,
and it's demand-led.
So, using it in conjunction with our other
leading indicators that this is likely to
feed into the real estate services sector
further down the line.
So, even though for goods, for all
commodities and the sub-indices for all
commodities is essentially in the
manufacturing sector, there is a very
obvious read-across to many services.
So, one of the most useful things we can
regularly do as traders or portfolio
managers is to stay on top of cyclical
commodity prices like energy and
industrial metals and determine as a whole
the general level of demand and use this
as a guide to future expected inflation
and GDP growth.
So, we are using it as a leading indicator
gauge.
Now, if you look on the screen on the
left-hand side, you will see the producer
price indices for goods and in goods, all
commodities.
And then you'll see the sub-indices for
all commodities, which are farm products,
processed foods and feeds, and also
industrial commodities.
And within industrial commodities, you
will see further sub-indices.
So, you'll see further sub-indices.
So, you'll see, for example, fuels and
related products and power.
You'll see lumber and wood products.
You'll see metals and metal products.
And also industrial commodities less
fuels.
And what we can do is if you look at the
major sub-category, which is industrial
commodities, we can actually, on the FRED
website, click on industrial commodities
and get taken to the page on the
right-hand side, which is the producer
price index by commodity industrial
commodities index.
So, this essentially isolates our
industrial cyclical commodities as a
group, as a whole.
And of course, we can always click in to
the sub-indices like lumber and wood
products, metals and metal products, fuels
and related products and power, industrial
commodities, less fuels.
We can always click in to those
sub-indices, bring up the pages and
download the data and really drill down
into the cyclical commodity indices
themselves.
But we look at the headline level, the All
Commodities Index, and we look at
Industrial Commodities Index, which
contributes to the All Commodities Index.
So, using these indices as a leading
indicator gauge, when cyclical commodities
are viewed as a group, their relative
price performance may show healthy or weak
demand from cyclical industries of the
manufacturing sectors of the US economy.
Now, prices may also go up or down based
on supply-side issues.
We mentioned this earlier.
If there is a constant demand and
tightening supply, prices will go higher.
That means we're getting inflation, okay?
So, we're getting inflation from a supply
issue, a tightening supply issue.
If there's constant demand, yet ever
increasing supply, prices will go down.
So, we have the opposite.
We have the opposite.
We have deflation from increases in supply
given a constant level of demand.
So, if at any point in time, we are
analyzing cyclical commodity prices and
indices, what we have to understand is, is
that if when we do our work, we determine
that the price is moving, whether that
increases or decreases,
if the price is moving because there's a
supply driven issue, we must temper our
ability to gauge future economic growth.
So, basically, with supply-side driven
inflation, cyclical commodities are going
up in price, not because of an overall
demand increase.
In this situation, real GDP may actually
fall because demand is constant, and in
this particular cyclical commodity, we
have a supply situation occurring, okay?
We have a supply issue that's causing the
price to go up, and demand is constant.
So, in the future, the read-across into
real GDP is a small read-across.
On the flip side, with supply-side driven
deflation, the cyclical commodity price is
going down, not because of an overall
demand decrease.
It's going down because of an oversupply
of the commodity, given a constant level
of demand.
And even in that situation, when the
commodity price goes down, real GDP in the
future may rise more than we expect.
So, when we have supply-side issues in a
particular cyclical commodity, and we
determine at any one time that this is
probably the reason why a cyclical
commodity is either going up in price, so
inflation, or down in price, deflation.
The read-across, the read-across, we have
to understand that the read-across in
forecasting real GDP is going to be much
weaker than if it was demand-led.
If it's demand-led, then cyclical
commodity prices are indicative of future
CPI and PPI levels, which is reported
monthly.
So, monthly inflation numbers, and of
future economic growth, so real GDP
growth, which is reported quarterly, so
expansion and contraction.
So, if at any one moment in time, we
determine that a cyclical commodity price
move is much more down to demand factors
than supply factors, then it has a direct
read-across to economic growth and, of
course, inflation.
And also, because we know cyclical
commodity prices are trading every day,
then they are leading inflation and GDP
stats.
This is essentially providing us, as
traders and PMs, with another leading
indicator gauge to the economy.
So, in the downloads area, you will see
the spreadsheet called Commodity Prices,
and you will see all the data for oil,
copper, lumber, and iron ore.
And you need to go through these
spreadsheets, and look at the commodities
price data, and look at the distribution
of returns analysis, so the statistical
distribution analysis for each one, and
understand the one, two, and three
standard deviation moves on a daily and
weekly basis for each of the commodity
prices.
Commodity prices, so each of the commodity
products.
And you need to combine this with the
information and sources in the PDF
document for the corresponding products
for oil, copper, lumber, and iron ore, and
learn about the supply and demand
dynamics.
Commodity prices, you make a combination
of these resources, and in the future,
when you're analysing commodity prices,
you will understand what a normal move is,
and what an abnormal move is, and you will
understand what's driving the price.
Now, something else you can use as an
indicator for future expected levels of
inflation and growth is the commitment of
traders reports for the cyclical
commodities that we're looking at.
So, let's have a look at what we call the
commitment of traders reports, or cut
reports.
We can use non-commercial transactions
data from the Commodity Futures Trading
Commission, the CFTC, as an indicator for
professional money manager positioning in
our cyclical commodities.
So, what this data actually is, is the
real positions, long and short, of the
smart money in the market.
It's the institutional and hedge fund
money.
So, when we analyse this, what are we
getting?
We are getting a sentiment gauge of future
expectations of inflation and GDP growth
from their positioning in cyclical
commodities.
So, we analyse this data regularly to get
a sense of how the smart money is
positioning itself in the market.
And this data can act, again, as a leading
gauge of future expected inflation, GDP
growth, and general stock market
direction.
So, specifically, what we want to know is
if the smart money are long or short a
particular cyclical commodity and by what
magnitude.
Now, these numbers have not fallen from
the magic fairy tree or fallen from the
sky.
They are real numbers.
These are the real positions, long and
short, of institutional and hedge fund
money.
They are real numbers.
Of course, if hedge funds are positioned
long, they are committed to the belief
that the commodity will go up in price.
Therefore, they are committed to cyclical
commodity inflation and, of course, vice
versa.
This is why it is called a commitment of
traders report.
And, by the way, when you look at this
data, what you also have to understand is
that the hedge fund community have been
through the same leading indicator
analysis as you have throughout the PTM
video series.
They are looking at the same things.
So, the COT report data is useful because
we can calculate turning points in
positioning in professional trader circles
in the hedge fund community.
Therefore, we are determining professional
trader or hedge fund sentiment and their
inflation and potential growth
expectations because of the positioning
that they currently have or changing in a
particular cyclical commodity.
Now, how do we actually go through this
data and determine inflation and growth
sentiment from the hedge fund community?
Well, in the downloads area, you'll see
the commitment of traders spreadsheet
file.
And we cover the cyclical commodities
space.
We've got all of our cyclical commodities
in there.
And you'll see the numbers for each of the
cyclical commodities on the screen here.
We've looked at copper as an example.
And you'll see the four columns that we're
looking at.
We're looking at total open interest.
We're looking at manager longs, manager
shorts, and we're looking at the net long
and short.
So, what do we do?
We do our analysis by taking the open
interest percentage change on both long
and short non-commercial hedge fund
positioning and work out the difference
between the two.
If we minus the percentage short
positioning from the percentage long
positioning, we get the difference between
the percentage of contracts that hedge
funds are long and short, which gives us
the net.
And what this does is create a new dynamic
that is known in professional trading
circles as the flip.
The flip basically shows us when hedge
funds flip from committing to being net
long to net short or net short to net
long.
And it also shows us how committed is the
commitment.
So, the rate of change by which
positioning is changing.
Now, if you look at the screen here, as
mentioned, we are using here copper as an
example.
And you can see our four columns.
And you can see on the screenshot that
we've taken, we've taken this directly
from the data in the spreadsheet download.
And we're looking at the period April 2020
to August 2020.
And you can see we've highlighted two
weeks in the data, which is the week of
the 26th of May and the week of the 2nd of
June.
And you can see on the right-hand side in
the fourth column, you can see the flip
occurring at this stage.
So, the flip occurs in the week of the 2nd
of June 2020.
What this means is, is that the net
positioning of the hedge fund community in
copper has gone from being net short to
net long.
So, they've gone from being, as the
professional trading community, going from
bearish to bullish.
So, right there in that week, you can see
the flip occurring.
Now, we can actually chart the commitment
of traders data for the entire history.
And that's available in the download as
well in the spreadsheet file.
You can have a look at this in the
spreadsheet.
And obviously, also look at the data in
all the columns that's feeding this chart.
And you can see on the screen where the
red arrow is pointing.
This is where the flip in copper occurred
in the week preceding June 2nd, 2020,
because the report is on the data for the
previous week.
So, if you think about this chart in its
entirety and think about periods that
we've looked at previously in the PTM
video series.
Think about the August 18 to August 19
period.
And think about the period when the Fed
was cutting rates over the summer of 2019.
And then the lead out of the turnaround in
the economy in the second half of 2019.
So, think about that period.
You can see on the commitments of traders
numbers when we look at 2018, we get a
peak.
And then the hedge fund community is
getting less long in copper.
So, they are less committed.
They are committed long, but less
committed.
And then we get a flip going negative
during that August 18 to August 19 period.
We bounce around at the 0% bound for a
number of months.
And then in the spring, summer of 2019,
that's when bearish sentiment or net short
positioning in the commitments of traders
reports or copper accelerates and goes
lower to a trough.
And then we get a trough coming out of
that trough when it seems the Fed's
actions began working and the commitment
of hedge fund traders, the hedge fund
community gets less short.
So, they're still committed short, but get
less committed.
And then we get the flip that we just
looked at where we get a flip positive in
2020 after COVID.
We did get a flip before where the hedge
fund community did go positive at the end
of 2019, beginning of 2020.
But COVID was obviously taking hold in the
first quarter of 2020.
And then we get the flip positive long
back in June 2020.
And we see this data borne out in prices
as well.
So, we can look at the copper price and
what was going on at these times visually
on the chart.
So, if we look at our cyclical commodity
copper price during that period, mid 2018
to the end of 2019, you can see the copper
price heading lower as the commitments of
traders, the hedge fund community gets
less and less long and then flip to short
and get bearish.
And then we have our recovery, where we
know during that period in 2019, where we
had the Fed cutting rates in July,
September, October 2019, we know they
started to take effect.
The interest rate cuts started to take
effect, our leading indicators were
turning around.
And then we have COVID, and then COVID
occurs, but then we get our flip
aggressively in the copper price from the
hedge fund community at the beginning of
June.
So, end of May, beginning of June, 2020.
So, at any one point in time, guys, for
cyclical commodities, you need to be
looking at the commitments of traders
reports and analyzing the flip.
The flip is where we tend to have turning
points in cyclical commodities, but you
also need to look at the extremes.
So, when the gap between positive and
negative sentiment becomes historically
wide either way.
So, we're looking at the peaks and the
troughs in commitments of traders reports
for cyclical commodities.
So, when we have extreme positive, it
basically means that longs versus shorts
are at or near historical highs.
When we have extreme negative, it's
because the longs and shorts, longs minus
shorts, are at or near historical lows.
So, when we witness these extremities in
cyclical commodities, it can be a signal
or a warning sign of potential turning
points.
However, guys, there is obviously no
rulebook here.
So, positioning and prices of a cyclical
commodity can stay at extreme positive or
extreme negative for a long time before
reversing.
So, don't take this as a rules-based
scenario where, for example, you're trying
to connect things in your mind where you
say,
if I see, for example, the copper
commitments of traders peaking, then I
should be looking to short copper stocks.
That's not the case because the definition
here of the positive data from the longs
minus the shorts being at extremes and
becoming slightly less extreme
So, what I mean is simply the hedge fund
community are still bullish.
They're just less committed than before.
So, it's a fallacy to read into this and
say, at, for example, a turning point from
a peak or a trough, I should directly read
across into the stock market and say,
I'm going to go short or long, for
example, copper stocks or construction
stocks from lumber.
It's obviously, it doesn't work like that,
guys.
It's not a rulebook where you take
positions simply based on the flip or the
extremities becoming slightly less extreme
in the commitments of traders reports
and directly reading across into positions
in stocks.
So, definitely do not do that.
You have to do the proper work, which is
looking at the actual demand and supply
dynamics as well to see if this is the
demand led or supply led in terms of price
movement.
What you're doing with the cyclical
commodities commitments of traders reports
is looking at sentiment and looking at it
in the context of your work on the demand
and supply dynamics.
And if you're seeing evidence that a
commodity price move, a cyclical commodity
price move, if you're seeing evidence that
it is demand led and you're seeing
evidence from the hedge fund community
that they are seeing it too and they are
getting committed one way or the other,
then what does that mean?
Well, it basically means that your
cyclical commodity that you're using can
be used as a leading indicator for future
economic growth and potential stock market
direction and returns.
Now, something else we can look at is the
US dollar trade weighted indices or TWI.
All major commodity benchmarks are priced
in US dollars.
If we get a fall in the US dollar, this is
generally inflationary, so prices going up
for our cyclical commodities.
As traders or PMs, we have to keep an eye
on the US dollar versus a basket or
baskets of rest of world currencies as an
indicator for expected CPI and PPI
inflation in the future.
So, if the US dollar weakens or
strengthens, we are likely to get higher
or lower commodity prices.
And remember, turning points and trends in
commodity prices must be backed by demand
evidence and data.
So, commodity prices moving in the inverse
direction to the US dollar move and
inventory levels rising or falling.
Now, there's three trade weighted US
dollar indices that we look at and they're
available in the trade weighted
spreadsheet file in the downloads area.
And don't worry, all of the links are in
there as well.
Our three indices that we look at are
three trade weighted US dollar indices are
firstly, the broad index for goods and
services.
Secondly, the advanced foreign economies
for goods and services.
And third, the US dollar index for
emerging markets economies for goods and
services.
And if you click through the links, for
example, to the broad index, you can see
the weightings of all of the currencies of
the US trading partners that are used.
So, you can see the weightings of the
currencies that make up the index.
That's for the broad index for the
advanced foreign economies and the
emerging markets economies index.
You can get the weights if you follow the
links to revisions to the Federal Reserve
dollar indices.
But you can use these as a guide for AFE
and for EME as well.
And for example, like with our other
indices that we've looked at, and we've
done this many times now, and you'll have
seen this in other spreadsheets.
You can go to the FRED website, have a
look at, for example, the broad index, and
you can download the data.
And yes, you've guessed it, you can run a
statistical distribution analysis, a
distribution of returns on the trade
weighted US dollar indices.
On the page here, we have the broad index,
and you can analyze, you know, we've done
the work for you here.
You can analyze, for example, two and
three standard deviation moves, both on a
daily basis, so using daily data, and on a
weekly basis, using weekly data.
So, daily data is on the left here, and
weekly data is on the right.
We can do that as well for the AFE index,
so the advanced foreign economies index,
have a look at our standard deviation
moves for daily and weekly data.
And we can do that for the emerging
markets economies as well.
So, the US dollar index, EME index, and we
look at the one, two, and three standard
deviation moves to determine, for each of
these indices,
what is a normal move on a daily basis,
and on a weekly basis, and what is an
abnormal move on a daily and weekly basis.
And we look to this for trends and turning
points.
So, in the future, when you're looking at
the data, so daily and weekly changes of
the trade weighted indices, and you see
what could be an abnormal move,
when compared to historical data, you will
know that we are probably experiencing a
change in macroeconomic conditions,
and potentially inflation expectations,
and GDP growth expectations for the United
States.
What we've also done for you, and I
mentioned this previously, in the
downloads area, is we've included a
summary file.
Now, the summary file for all of our
cyclical commodities, and for the US
dollar trade weighted indices, calculates
beautifully, all in one screen,
for daily and weekly data, the one, two,
and three standard deviation moves in the
negatives and the positives for all of our
products.
So, this is data that you're going to be
updating when new data comes out, and
you'll be doing this on a regular basis.
And when you look at the price data of
cyclical commodities, and when you're
putting it into the context of demand and
supply dynamics,
looking for demand-led price moves,
looking for demand-led price moves, and
when you're looking at it in the context
of the commitments of traders reports,
and the trade weighted indices, you're
going to have a very clear picture of
what's going on, and using the cyclical
commodities prices in themselves as
leading indicators.
So, in summary, cyclical commodities
prices. As traders and PMs, we have access
to them. We have access to several
cyclical commodities prices that can act
as leading indicator gauges to levels of
future inflation, real GDP growth, and
stock market direction, and possible
returns.
We have to keep on top of the most common
cyclical commodities prices. We have to
keep on top of the most common cyclical
commodities prices in both the energy and
industrial metals spaces.
So, in the oil market, copper, iron ore,
and in addition, lumber in the
construction market, we have to be on top
of them, and we have to gauge demand,
supply, and inventory dynamics.
Also, when we're analyzing prices, we need
to look, when we're looking at cyclical
commodities prices, to normal and abnormal
moves as clues for turning points and
trends of inflation and growth
expectations.
We have to keep on top of the cyclical
commodities, we have to keep on top of the
cyclical commodities in order to gauge
what the smart money sentiment of
inflation and growth expectations is at
any one moment in time in the market.
So, we also regularly have to keep on top
of the cyclical commodities, and we also
regularly have to keep an eye on the US
dollar trade-weighted indices for normal
and abnormal moves for turning points and
trends.
And, of course, even though they are
coincidental indicators, we will also be
on top of monthly inflation numbers.
We will be on top of CPI and PPI, and we
will know what normal and abnormal moves
are that show up in the later monthly
releases.
So, taken together with our other leading
indicators, understanding and being on top
of both normal and abnormal moves in our
cyclical commodity prices and the US
dollar trade-weighted indices.
Plus, also knowing market sentiment from
the COT reports, gives us an additional
leading edge and gauge to predict future
inflation, GDP growth, stock market
direction and potential returns.
These are useful indicators, but we have
to understand the context that we have to
view them in.
As long as we know that, they are useful
indicators going forward at any one moment
in time that we can add to our leading
indicator list.
Okay, so in video 11, we covered the NFIB,
SBO index and why it's useful.
And then we made a jump.
We jumped from surveys in the United
States to analyzing cyclical commodity
prices.
So, why did we go and do this?
Well, there's two main reasons.
Firstly, at this stage, after we've
covered money markets and surveys in the
United States,
it's the right time in terms of your
educational development and progression to
get an understanding of inflation and
supply side factors.
So, in this case, inflation is downstream
from both demand and supply, but supply
side factors can affect leading
indicators, especially in the
manufacturing sectors.
So, commodity prices and understanding
them, so cyclical commodity prices,
understanding them, it gives us a gauge on
future levels of inflation and therefore
real GDP.
So, gross domestic product adjusted for
inflation.
So, it also not only gives us that, it
gives us, obviously, if we understand real
GDP growth direction, we get a better
understanding of stock market direction
and we also get a better read for our
portfolio bias.
We just have a general overall better
understanding of what's going on in the
economy.
Secondly, cyclical commodities are not
just quoted in US dollars and tradable in
the United States.
They are also traded in other geographies
around the world and they're denominated
in those geographies in different
currencies.
So, we will be moving on to international
surveys next.
So, at this juncture, again, in terms of
your educational development and
progression, covering cyclical commodities
is the right thing to do here.
Now, in the downloads area, there are
multiple spreadsheets for analyzing
cyclical commodity price data, but also
there's a PDF which outlines all of the
supply side factors to take into
consideration when analyzing the data.
So, that's really there for you to
determine at any one time whether a move
is demand-led or supply-led.
So, bring yourself up to speed with all of
those resources and watch the video over
again if you need to.
Okay, so we're going to move on now to
international surveys.
So, we're going to be looking at leading
indicator surveys in both Europe and
China.
So, in video 13, we'll be looking at
Europe and in video 14, we'll be looking
at China.
So, let's shoot over straight away to
video 13.
Let's get straight into it and I'll see
you at the end of the video back at the
desk.